awesome so now box2d is created and can
be updated each frame our next step is
to add physics bodies to the world so
that we can simulate them properly to
create a physics object we have to jump
through a few hoops the first thing we
need to do is actually create a body def
object now a body definition object is
going to be used later to actually
create our body but what we do here is
that we actually set some specific
properties on it for example whether or
not it's dynamic or static think of
static objects as the ones that will
never move in your environment
walls trees stone chickens things like
that dynamic bodies are the ones that
move in to react to physics once you've
set your properties for your body
definition you need then to call world
create body this will actually tell
box2d
to create a physics object based on the
definitions that you just passed into it
and of course it will return a handle to
this object so that you can use it to
once your object has actually been
created the next thing you need to do is
actually set the physics properties on
the object box2d does this using what
they call a fixture definition now
fixture definition defines properties
that allow you to set the density
friction restitution mass things along
these lines basically how this object is
going to interact with the physics of
the world around it generally in a game
you'll have groups of objects that all
resemble the same similar physical
characteristics as such you may want to
go through and actually group them into
certain types of fixtures for grits we
actually have the majority of the
objects in the world use a specific type
of fixture object that react to the
world same way however we have one type
of bullet that can be launched from the
bouncy bullet gun that actually uses a
different fixture as such we allow the
entity def object passed in from the
user to actually have a flag defining
whether or not this is a bouncy fixture
object from there we can actually set
the density and friction differently so
that it hits the wall and contains its
velocity moving forward as you write
your game application it's probably
worthwhile to take into account how all
things should react in the environment
and use different fixtures appropriately
now once you have defined the fixture
information about how the world should
react with the object we actually need
to define the shape of the object the
shape is the most critical as it defines
how this object should interact with the
rest of the world now box2d has support
for polygons circles and oddly enough
boxes right and who'd a thunk
now it's worth pointing out that most
physics engines support a suite of whole
definition
but give huge performance wins to
simplistic hulls like spheres circles
boxes and cubes polygons are always an
option but expect to pay a performance
penalty for the flexibility you're
gaining the fixture of definition
supports a suite of these api's such as
the set as box method which of course
will define the fixture definition as a
box once you've got all these parameters
set you call the create fixture method
on side of the body definition that's
been given to you and this will
effectively attach the shape and
information to the body definition from
there you're pretty much done you've got
a physics object that will react to the
world and do all the things you tell it
to do so go ahead and return it out to
the calling function